there was this class I was taking in
high school and we had to write a report
on the opening ceremony of the 2004
Olympic Games the building the stadium
for the games designed by Santiago
Calatrava
shocked me I'd never seen anything like
it I didn't even know architecture could
look like that so after the games I
ended up looking more into his work what
other buildings he had done other
architects like Frank Gehry and Antonio
Gaudi and after a few weeks I decided
that that's really where I wanted to go
in terms of my career
I'm interested in the area of responsive
environments if you look at the fields
of computation and architecture they
moved to completely different paces you
have architecture which evolves sort of
over the period of decades of the
average life cycle of modern building 50
years or so whereas computation your
cellphone changes every year to 18
months processor speeds are doubling
every 18 months
how is architecture going to keep up
with that the Robert R Taylor fellowship
is named after the first
african-american students here at MIT
who graduated an architecture program
and now it's been set up as a fellowship
program to recruit minority students
interested in architecture when I
applied to the computation program at
the same time that I found out that I
had gotten in I found out that I had
received the fellowship the fellowship
covers full tuition and a living stipend
for while I'm here of completing a
computation program without the
fellowship it probably would have been
out of my reach financially to
look at graduate school so it really
does make that sort of difference and I
think it makes a lot of different stuff
for minority students possibly
interested in architecture because I
mean it's a very it's a very expensive
profession I mean you have five years or
more of college level education that you
have to go through in order to even be
in the position to get experience
towards becoming an architect question
is how can we make that more financially
feasible for those who otherwise
minority students who might otherwise go
into some other profession
you